the fact that people argue with me on
this reading thing and people argue with
me about mentors no just use your own
gut feeling is that how you learn
English when you were 2 years old you
use your gut feeling to start
conjugating verbs no you learn from
other people becoming a learning machine
and a person who invests in the cell
works you can only pick one thing that
you want out of life and if you pick the
wrong thing you'll never really be
successful need motivation hey watch
this top 10 with believe nation believe
Asia what's up it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see exploded onto the world so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you grab a snack
and chew in today's lessons from a man
who dropped out of college and was
completely broke having to go back home
and sleep on his mom's couch to helping
launch more than 20 multi-million dollar
business and creating one of the world's
largest book club with 1.5 million
subscribers he's Tai Lopez and here's my
take on his top 10 rose a success vol 2
enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one my personal favorite find
mentors the [ __ ] that people argue with
me on this reading thing and people
argue with me about mentors no just use
your own gut feeling is that how you
learn English when you were 2 years old
you use your gut feeling to start
conjugating verbs no you learn from
other people you learn manners you learn
language you learn all things valuable
you learn to drive from another person
so it doesn't make sense you learn life
so books are just the mentors who maybe
are dead now you wanna learn about Steve
Jobs
he ain't alive to teach you but you can
learn through accumulated wisdom and
that's why trust me I meet I very few
powerful businessman I've ever met
don't read a lot Warren Buffett who I
think's the best businessman by far in
the world because doesn't see has 75
companies that he pretty much runs 200
billion in revenue he reads 8 hours a
day
he reads 600 he said he slowed down in
his old age I only reads 500 pages a day
Bill Gates goes on reading vacations
Mark Zuckerberg just start started a
reading once a week book club on
Facebook and I already got a couple
million fathers and now with audiobooks
there's no excuse you got YouTube videos
let this thing run in the background
like you want to become like a
supercomputer it is download smart crap
from smart people and you pick and
choose like some people are like Thai I
don't agree with everything you say I'm
like good I don't agree with everything
I said like a year later I'm like wait I
was wrong I see people making fun of the
Kardashians I'm like you gonna make fun
of the Kardashians look Kylie Jenner the
youngest Kardashian in the last 18
months has done four hundred million
dollars in revenue on lipstick kits and
various make up things with Kylie
cosmetics put that in perspective
Lauria maybelline massive brands it took
them 50 years as an organization with
thousands of employees to do a Kylie
Jenner did by herself at 20 at 18 you're
gonna laugh at the Kardashians do you
have to agree with everything the
Kardashians know but like Abraham
Lincoln said I learned from everybody
even if sometimes it's
not to do so you can just go into the
Kardashians reverse-engineer their
success Co I like this I like this I
like this I don't like that then leave
out what you don't like rule number 2
work smarter
I know single mom my mom was a single
mom all around us family single moms
people trying to put food on their table
working two three jobs is the answer for
them to just work harder or is it to
work smarter work hard or work smart
because they're different I'm always
reminded of this story that my mentor
Alan nation told me he said Ty and I
don't know if there's a truce for it but
it gets the point across
there was a plane flying over South
America it crash-landed and it was full
of all these engineers all these hard
workers and the hard workers got out and
were so machetes and they all grabbed a
machete and they begin to hack their way
through the jungle chop chop chop chop
chop flurries of activity boy they were
working hard but they forgot something
don't ever confuse flurries of activity
with accomplishment activity doesn't
always equal achievement so they were
chopping through and luckily for them
one person got out of the plane instead
of working hard when ton climbed up a
big tree and looked out and surveyed the
landscape and yelled down to the group
and said hey guys you're working hard
but you're going the wrong direction
you're going deeper into the jungle the
city for our escape is the other way you
see what's move civilization forward is
not just hard work go to any hotel got
any restaurant the hardest-working
people there are working their ass off
and they're still not getting ahead
there's still not equality in pay
there's still people making massive
amounts who don't work nearly as hard as
the working-class know what's gets you
ahead is leverage in fact it's the exact
opposite what you want to do is how to
figure out how to work half the time and
get twice as much done so that you could
take a vacation so that you can in paint
a painting and have time some downtime
so you can go on vacation with your
family so you can just lay out on the
beach and just look at nature and enjoy
life you want to just grind yourself
into the ground go ahead but the people
that get ahead are not just grinders
they are not the grind is necessary
worked as necessary but it's never a
goal it's a necessity the goal is very
different the goal of life is not to
breathe breathing as a necessity
the goal of life is to enjoy your life
to do something important you breathe
because you must you work because you
must but you never say well you know
what I you know why I'm here is just a
breathe no you're not here just the work
working harder doesn't always change the
game rule number three find your
motivation most people procrastinate
because they don't feel confident that
the what they're doing really motivates
them if you're really motivate motivated
you it what you wouldn't procrastinate
it's like a 14 year old kid that the mom
and dad can't get the kid to do anything
but the kids motivated play video games
Kittel ride his bike across town to buy
a video game and come back like so
there's motivation there the parents
just don't wanna find it and as you grow
you have to know how to find deep within
yourself that motivation and once you
have motivation you have no problem with
procrastination rule number four be a
perfectionist people you have to know
how to double check your work it's that
simple it doesn't mean you're always a
perfectionist but it means when it's
important when you're a pilot of an
airplane double check before you go they
if you get on a plane you hear the
pilots double-checking the copilot going
you know hydraulics and the guy goes
hydraulics but and that's why planes
don't crash and it's called Six Sigma
it's three defects per million your goal
in business and in life on the important
things is to make three mistakes per
million transactions in the only way you
do that is by being a perfectionist in
terms of double-check this rule number
five have thick skin a lesson in
branding whenever trying to brand
yourself or any company if you change
your brand from what it used to be at a
rig right away you can get resistant so
most people when they get a little
resistance but mostly what optic skin
and then they stop but over time if you
keep branding yourself in the new brand
then
eventually it catches on like I used to
not have much fitness stuff so when I
fired to start putting Fitness stuff
people are like what is all this Fitness
now eventually people just associate
that with you and they forget there was
a time when you didn't do it so that's a
good tip on branding you have to have
thick enough skin because it's kind of
like when Facebook changed every time
they changed their interface people go
nuts oh I hate this but in three months
later they can't remember those plenty
and then when you change you a new one
they say no we like the one before but
that one before is the one they hated it
because it was a change from the version
of you know one before but Mark
Zuckerberg smarter than people that's
why it just keeps changing it
whatever is better and then people
eventually like it same when Instagram
changed their logo snapchat changed
their you know people always a lot of
people have low OH meaning low openness
to new experience they automatically
hate anything new rule number six invest
in yourself and I'm telling you becoming
a learning machine and a person who
invests in the cell works I invest at
least a hundred thousand dollars a month
in my own education literally 100 G's a
month not a year I got a CPA back that
number up I've shown it it's it's
obvious - if you watched my snapchat
traveling mentors coaches consultants
that I pay and I've been doing that for
years and it's funny the more I invested
myself every year my income has gone up
massively some people go oh well I'm not
gonna pay for stuff I'm just gonna
google it well go ahead but I'm telling
you there is a magic it investing in
yourself people get it invested in real
estate it's good oh okay I do that
invest in stock more that's good
i buy land I know I'm investing by
businesses it's all good but nothing
touches the ROI on investing in my own
brain rule number seven be organized the
next one is organization I can't tell
you how much better my life is and
anybody watching this will be if you
wake up every single day and you take
ten minutes I have yellow notepad
sitting all around my house I got that
from Bill Gates Bill Gates bill right
Soph at 17 by locking himself in a hotel
room was six yellow notepads and he rode
out the whole basic code for boss and
things that built Microsoft okay
he became the richest man in the world
18 years straight because he was
organized enough to lock himself in a
room and think through his day and so
what I try to do and whenever I do this
I have a great day whenever I don't I
notice it be organized a little bit ten
minutes I actually have this little
couch thing outside of my shower and I
put a notepad by it I take a shower when
I wake up I walk over to that I kind of
sit there and I just write out I mean it
can be as little as three main projects
you want to get done that day rule
number eight optimize for the right
things if I can go back time there one
thing I'm telling you right now it's
this you can only pick one thing that
you want out of life and if you pick the
wrong thing you will never really be
successful let me back up
my mentor Joe South has said the worst
thing in life is to get older and
realize you got good at the wrong thing
and I see people that are very wealthy
but I don't admire I live here in
Beverly Hills is billionaires all up and
down the street doesn't mean I would
trade lies for me in fact the best test
is I called the exchange tested would
you trade lives and the reason that
almost anybody I meet I wouldn't trade
live for them it's not because they're
not smart on because they're not good
people it's because one simple thing
they are optimizing for the wrong thing
so let's say you say I want to be an
entrepreneur that's not something you
should optimize for that's ridiculous
here's why you haven't one life maybe
will go to heaven or hell laughter maybe
there's an act like maybe there are
maybe there isn't
in there so I can't speak on but I can
tell you you get one chance on this
planet and if you optimize for an
entrepreneur what about your health what
about love
what about happiness I'm a miserable
entrepreneurs that are fat out of shape
I don't want to be them I know a dude
that not a close friend of mine but a
friend of an entrepreneur friend this
guy's a billionaire but he's so fat he
can't get out of bed his two billion
dollars has a private 747 jet so what I
want to be him no he optimized for the
wrong thing he optimized to make two
billion dollars but he forgot why would
you want to have two billion dollars of
Etan how health I always remember what
rolls out that said nothing worse in
life then realizing you've got good at
the wrong thing
that guy got good at the wrong thing
it's irrefutable you cannot argue with
that why would you give your health up
to gain money there's a saying that when
people are young they lose their health
to get wealth and when they're old they
use their wealth to get back their
health it's a circular logic and
circular in this case is illogical it's
stupid if you are stupid most of it if I
could go back in time I realize most
people are lost literally most people
are lost I don't I'm talking about the
people who write you know I got the
biggest book club in the world
I know top authors and all these people
they might be smart in one specific
domain but if you look at their life I
wouldn't exchange for it there's a few
people that I have met that when I look
back online
even though one of them Arnold
Schwarzenegger not everything but he was
healthy he was strong he changed the
world he'd made gyms hot gyms come from
unfortunately he made all the gyms all
over marriages from Arnold
now other people worked on it but not
like him he motivated people who came
self-made millionaire before 30 he
wanted to act
acting's in art he was an artist he
can't you know maybe it wasn't the best
actor in the world he's not bad I was
actually in his kitchen a couple months
ago just like this I mean him talking
smoking cigars he's a good actor like I
said he might not be you know caddy
award but he got the good life
his son was there his kids were there at
his house he's happy he's friends you
got social life you gotta have health
love love happiness if you at any point
optimize it for anything that doesn't
involve all four of them you're making
the biggest mistake in the world rule
number nine build an elite team here
that you got to do to build a team first
of all number one you got to realize no
one ever did anything big
without an elite team around them Bill
Gates said he never did anything alone
except take tests he said he had Steve
Ballmer he had fallen he had a hundred
thousand employees behind him to build
Microsoft and the biggest company in the
world same with Facebook the same with
all saying with Elon Musk that
realization will help you put in the
time and motivate you to have an effort
to want to put in the effort number two
thing is you have to train formally
everybody knows they need to train their
employees but they do it in a very
informal haphazard way which doesn't
work what does formal training look like
well
maybe a little bit like a classroom a
dedicated room that your employees go
into a dedicated time pen and paper
drills exercises quizzes testing for
retention
then number three you've got to look
over their shoulder because once you do
the formal training
you can't expect memory retention to be
perfect so it must be continued over the
shoulder style training my main hope is
that that you'll take away the concept
of a formal training program most
entrepreneurs train very haphazard
leaving train only in crisises well
that's not going to cut it the only
train during crisis is they guess what
your blood pressure is gonna be through
the roof and you're only putting out
fires prevent fires prevent fires
prevent fires so you should have at
least a three time a week training
program for airports dealers really are
wonderful this should feel formal there
should be a curriculum to it there
should be understanding when they walk
in the classroom or the training room
what they'll learn for that day
there should be evaluations
don't just be like most of the small
business owners that don't have an elite
team because they never took the time
they never understood the importance
there
lies the training and I never followed
up on the train and rule number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is have fun I'm back here in my
garage just got this new Lamborghini but
you know what I'm more proud of sir
you're uploading YouTube videos talking
about your pause yes sir in your house
yes sir sorry about this sorry sir uh uh
the bushes I trimmed them though I
trimmed them look how clean this thing
looking right now okay sorry sir I got
going to lose my job
now I've got three very special bonus
clips from Thai on how to seek
adventures say thank you and master the
art of living but before that I want to
know which of the rules in the first ten
meant the most to you are you going to
apply somehow to your life and your
business and how are you going to do it
write down the comments below make a
commitment when you write a commitment
down you're much more likely to actually
take some action so let's see in the
comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love see
you soon and enjoy the bonus clips
if you think about life you can be
nihilistic about life like what's the
purpose at the end of the day you can
dissect anything and go what's the
purpose some people go you know I want
to make a billion dollars and you can
say to them what's the purpose we all
die we all end up in the same small
grave at the end of the day and you can
say I want to become super intelligent I
want to have them get married and have
kids at the end of the day all flesh is
grass and you disappear just like the
grass eventually so for me the best
guess I had it maybe other people have
spiritual things and all that and the
best guess I've ever come up with is
like if every day you wake up and you go
I don't have it all figured out let's
jump into something crazy and see what
happened that's how I got started on
social media I started really be
dabbling with it in 2012 2013 in 2014 if
someone was like you should do YouTube
it's gonna be big so I was like let's
try a new adventure and I just started
shooting my first videos and January
25th 2016 2015 sorry I put out this
video and it it's ended up to me
literally different versions have like
600 million views it's gotten a lot of
views pencil a garage here in my garage
and some other similar garage themed
ones everybody should try to be rich and
famous at least once and should get it
just to realize it's not as good as you
think but the adventure part school and
also when I say adventure I also mean
gaining insight into life the biggest
thing I've learned if I could be 18
again I wish somebody had told me
basically nobody knows what they're
doing
even the adults you think you know
everybody's lost in the world is the
blind leading the blind so the ultimate
adventure to me is not just like bungee
jumping or something like that are going
to the Amish it's trying to get insight
and see life as a puzzle and your goal
in life is to seek the adventures that
piece the puzzle together so that at the
end of your life you like kind of get
get it you kind of get it I feel like
most people don't get what life is well
the best piece of advice that nobody
follows
right here say thank you huh I can't
tell you how many people call miss a
towel on a network
I don't be able to meet influencers
powerful people and blah blah blah get
investors I'm like you don't even say
thank you
I'm experimenting here with some crazy
diets I had some Swedish bitters got
some probiotics you know everything you
eat can't be sweet if you want to be
healthy just like every piece of advice
you get can't be healthy most people
need to wake up say thank you if I do a
conference I mean a party at my house I
invite two three four five hundred
people mark my words
every single time at most ten people
right thank you at most people are
entitled in this world but never get mad
they'll get their own reward their own
punishment
they'll be broke cuz like attracts like
you know who the ten people are that
always write me thank you if I do a big
party open bar open on my house without
a doubt it'll be the billionaires the
millionaires the a-list celebrities
those are the ones who say say thank you
that's why they're a list that's why
there are billionaires and millionaires
you got a reverse engineer their success
they did the stuff that most entitled
people won't do I know some people gonna
get mad said Todd you seem angry in this
I'm not angry I already know the secret
huh I always I caught the one for one
principle some does one thing for you
you do one thing for them always you
never let that ratio get out of whack
and Burt prudence is the ability to make
the right decision and I can't tell you
how many entrepreneurs and non
entrepreneurs even me at times - I'm not
special I'm lumping all of us in this
because of our upbringing in society our
goal is let's say our goal is like that
camera right there so let's assume
that's north so I have this compass in
my brain and my goal is to go right
there let's say it's a mile away so
north what happens if society my
upbringing in school wired my compass
exactly backwards so I think let's say I
can't see that camera but I know I want
to go north so I pull out like my
compass and it points that way so I
just take off walking and I do it in an
organized fashion I do it in a
perfectionist manner I'm perfecting my
steps in my posture I'm also working on
you know hard work and hustle keep
walking towards your goal well the truth
is if you go south when you should go
north you could have gone one mile but
the earth is about 24,000 miles in
circumference so you get to walk
twenty-four thousand miles and you'll
come up on the back side and you will
get your goal that's most entrepreneurs
the average person takes 20 years to
become a millionaire 90% of businesses
fail within the first five years 80 to
90 depend on what statistic most people
I did the math once the average American
has $60,000 saved by the time they're
about 60 years old so my answer I did
the math you can do this with a simple
financial calculator everybody in
America your parents everybody you know
will be a millionaire if they live to
160 at 160 years old you take 60 grand
at age 60 and you give it a decent
return on investment 8% 10% you'll be a
millionaire at 160 but the problem is
the great philosopher I think was
Aristotle Socrates said the problem is
art is long but life is short the art of
living and getting to your objective is
long but it doesn't have to be it's long
if your compass is backwards so the
whole point of what I'm saying about
adventure at the beginning is I'm trying
to take myself and point it to the true
north and you have to learn that from
books and mentors and a life experience
and listening and finding in-person
mentors and all those things they help
adjust your compass and most people are
gonna get what they want just about 40
years longer are there like key
principles though that you can use to
turn that compass of north actually
points north yes first one is just like
Alcoholics Anonymous admit you're lost
and that one's hard for people you tell
people even for me sometimes I want to
think I'm smart and I got it all figured
out and sometimes I'm like wait a sec
I'm still lost and not that the
acquiescence the
mittens of the fact that you're still
lost it gets you on track a lot faster
so if you're watching this and you feel
lost it's better to just sit down and be
like I'm lost because the day you admit
you're lost is the day you allow
yourself to be found by people who can
give you a tip raise your standard Apple
at the core its core value is that that
people need passion not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your acceptance of
me I don't ever give up I'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten roses success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link the description for
details